how many best picture oscar winners can
you name starting in 1990 all the way
through today i'll give you one hint
um there are 33 33 okay uh let's let's
start with with most recent coda we'll
go back we'll do parasite we'll do nomad
land
spotlight
um
12 years a slave god damn
uh
let's go to titanic let's go to
um
argo
uh
oh man i'm feeling miserably at this and
i call myself the awards ace this is a
problem okay great
i gotta think of you okay so the thing
obviously okay
what should have won i can tell you
right now just doing this list and what
already annoys me that i'm doing this
that i'm thinking that the social
network did not win best picture and for
that the whole thing just makes me just
want to ah i mean this is you're talking
about a film in my estimation it's
perfect so when you when you watch the
social network and you find out the
king's speech one best picture over it
that just makes me furious
why do you think that is
because there's so few films that we see
that are
truly spectacular across the board
really
exemplary
in every single aspect and when you
watch the social network you're looking
at a film that obviously direction
screen play cinematography score the
resonant raw score is is i think that's
the cherry on top that's what makes that
film
the
true masterpiece that it is is that it's
the choices that resident ross did in
that score from that opening scene when
he's walking across harvard square you
say oh my god this is unique and this
was not a choice that most composers
would do and in the fact that fincher
allowed them to work in that space and
create something again if you give that
to any other composing duo composer
singular you're talking about a
different film because they're not going
to come up with that score and i think
that is really what cements that as a
masterpiece but performances
everything in that film is is perfection
and the fact that it didn't win best
picture is again just i think it's got
to be the biggest crime in the history
of the oscars the fact that it did not
win best picture
and then the king's speech what is it
about that film or maybe it's nothing
it's just in comparison that's what it
is it's not about it's not about the
king's speech it's about
selecting for me it's it's it's really
about identifying what's the best film
what is the best film that we saw this
year that hits everything that you're
looking for and i think when i watch a
film and i try to say more of a film
evaluator than a film critic you look at
it and you say
what are the aspects that shine here
what what is truly worthy of
spotlighting this for an awards purposes
and when you watch a film
like again social network you see it in
every single category you're looking for
literally everything even production
design which is lower down the list for
that film but it still
creates a world which is very hard to do
um and i think that's one of the key
components for for any film is world
building and that is production design
and i think that when you when you have
a film that hits everything and it
doesn't win
that's what that's the hard part that's
the thing for me it's like yeah it's at
the end of the day it's just a trophy
that says you're the best film doesn't
mean it is but it should have been that
film that year and that's what i think
it is it's not about king speech it's
about social network being truly
perfection well it's public
acknowledgement too
and and acknowledgement of a group of
sort of gatekeepers that say okay you're
worthy and so 2011 king's speech did you
know going in there's no way the social
network's going to win no i thought for
sure listen
at the end of the day you still have
hope they're going to pick the right the
number one film right and yours might be
different but overall when you look at
in your you know you watch
hundreds of films a year and you see the
one that is very clearly the best film i
mean i go back obviously they got it
right with parasite another film that is
true perfection uh occasionally uh they
are going to miss it's just gonna happen
it's just the law of averages are going
to say that it's going to go to
something else i mean this year i
wouldn't have picota uh uh for sure um i
mean i think i think coda is
is a very likable film do i think that
it holds up to the you know when we look
back at oscar's 2022 are we going to say
coda is filmmaking that is truly going
to
you know pass the test of time i don't
think so
i think it's a it's a likable film but i
just don't think it hits again when i
watch a film for me it's really
technical it's so
important to a film the tech for me is
where i really get dialed in like when i
watch the batman i mean i see matt
reeves and i say this is a director when
i go back and i much let me in
you just know that this is a
a person that has a skill
that is extremely unique and they have a
vision that is singular and those are
the
things that for me
as i'm assessing you know awards value
for a film you're you those are the
films that you want to see succeed
so a director like ty west who's
creative and edgy
will he ever receive an oscar not for x
i mean he's not he's not going to win
for x uh but when you watch and i go
back and i remember innkeepers from tai
west and i don't remember
thinking too much of that film or the
direction but whatever happened between
innkeepers roughly a decade ago and x i
mean x is when you watch that film you
are looking at a director who has again
that skill
that is in the artistic vision that most
people don't possess
and it's it could be a traditional
remake of texas chainsaw massacre right
and it's not it is it's got so many
layers to it and i think the choice is
the landslide scene in x um you know the
fleetwood mac i mean that is truly
when you watch that film the way it's
edited
the way it organically flows from the
film uh and just all of a sudden he
starts on the guitar and it starts into
the montage of through the years it is
that is the best sequence that i have
seen in several years um as a singular
sequence of a film the landslide
sequence in x uh do i hope ty west will
be
a best director one day absolutely and i
think he no question he possesses the
skill uh but he's been working in the
horror realm let's hope i know he's got
pearl coming up later this year they
shot him back to back right they shot
the prequel
and during well they shot x so pearl's
coming out this fall
and i can't wait to see that as well but
he's someone that's on the radar as
somebody who you know going forward i
would not be surprised if this is
somewhere we're talking about in the in
the finchers in the nolans you know if
we'll know so when we get up to that top
level tai west is absolutely going to be
there one day sure sure and he's still
very young oh yeah
i don't even know how old he is
he's probably his late 20s 30s but he's
got such a i think that's when you watch
a film when when i go to see films
you're really looking for that talent
that pops and you say wow this is again
remarkable skill
and
singular vision that the average person
you know you see so many films and you
see decent direction you see above
average direction and then you see what
ty west did
or david fincher in social network or
any number of films obviously from
fincher but when you get to those that
that level of skill
is is uh that's the treat that's the
cinematic treat that we're all looking
for
so 1990 driving miss daisy
1991 dances with wolves 92 silence of
the lambs 93 unforgiven 94 schindler's
list 95 forest gump 96 braveheart
97 the english patient 98 titanic 99
shakespeare in love
2 000 american beauty 2001 gladiator
2002 a beautiful mind 2003 chicago 2004
the lord of the rings the return of the
king 2005 one of my favorite excuse me
uh million dollar baby
2006 another favorite crash 2007 the
departed 2008. no country for old men
2009 slumdog millionaire
2010.
oh i loved it anymore
yes you do love danny dave when we have
yes yeah you can keep okay okay
oh my god
yeah okay all right so we're paying
homage to anyway
2010 hurt locker 2011 the king's speech
2012 the artist
2013 argo
2014 12 years a slave 2015 birdman yes
2016 spotlight
20. yeah 2017 moonlight 2018 the shape
of water 2019 green book 2020 parasite
2021 nomad land
2022
coda
okay i mean overall when you when you
list off the
when we go back to 1990 you look at
those films i there's not a whole
there's not a film in there that i say
wow this is not
worthy of being best picture i don't see
there's not one even crash i mean listen
i'm not suggesting the crash is is the
all-time best movie ever made but i
understand how people respond to the
film i think that's one of the things
that you have to be able to do when you
go in and you critique a film or
evaluate a film is you're trying to for
me
is figure out
what is the audience for this film
and
do you understand how this audience for
the film will be able or will not be
able to embrace this film and i think
that when you watch a film
um like top gun maverick
you you see it i saw it you know three
weeks ago before it opened and i said
this is a film that will be loved
by 99 of the people that see it 99
because it is that
it's it gives you everything that you
want for a movie going experience for
the average moviegoer right
understand the spectrum of moviegoers is
extremely wide and and but at the end of
the day when you're talking about a film
that's going to appeal to a large swath
of the movie going public
you have to identify something like top
gun maverick is going to work and it did
i said it's going to get a plus cinema
score it did which means perfect word of
mouth right that means people are going
out of topcoat maverick and they're
saying you have to see this film which
doesn't happen very often that that true
organic
love for a film that spreads like
wildfire because everybody who goes to
see it comes run out and they become an
apostle like hey you gotta go see top
gun maverick and that's what's happening
and i think when you look back at from
1990 on to most these films most of
those films have that even koda which i
said i have plenty of issues with from a
filmmaking perspective it still has that
aspect of word of mouth being strong
where people say oh i really liked coda
and you need to have that because that's
in king's speech is that way
so you understand how that happened
people like the feel that the king's
speech gives you
conversely i understand how the social
network is not an uplifting film but it
doesn't have to be like there's no law
that says films have to be uplifting one
of the things i love about a film from
the past
uh two plus decades up in the air is the
fact that it isn't
uh a buttoned up ending in bow tie and
everybody he gets the girl that's what
makes up in the air the film it is same
with la la land exact same thing is i
think that's what makes the the film
what it is is the fact that it's not
a perfect finish to a film but
some audience people members do not like
that they want they want to have they
want to go home feeling good and so i
think that's
that will that's why people don't like
la la land as much or up in the air i
remember my ex-wife at the time was like
i hate it up in the air why you didn't
get the girl i'm like that's why it's
good
that's exactly why it's good
where did you see the first top gun
yeah once a while yeah i was i was uh
you know an 80s kid and top gun came out
and it was
listen you go back to the 80s and you
know i mean listen we grew up a similar
era and and you you say to yourself uh
what a difference it was back then right
because back then it was just you didn't
you had three networks okay and pbs we
didn't even have fox at that time you
had television you had radio that was it
right and you had movies
and
you went to a movie and that's all you
had so you had this
just everyone would talk about one thing
which we don't have as much anymore
these days because there's so many
choices to what you can spend your free
time on your entertainment time on back
then it was movies
network television or radio and when we
would go to the movies and i saw top gun
and uh it just you know i was a young
kid growing up i'm like i want to be
like maverick i want to be that guy and
uh you know this the soundtrack you came
we all had the cassette not the cd cds
weren't around not the vinyl although i
had vinyl didn't have the vinyl that had
the cassette wore it out
cbs records i remember going backwards
and forwards backwards and boards on
that thing because in the old days for
those of you who don't remember the the
cassettes were pain in the butt to go
for the next song you had to fast
forward and hit it perfectly at the
right time but but that film was a
phenomenon i mean it was what everybody
was talking about top gun was the thing
i remember being uh in high school and
they had the top gun uh
we had like assembly and and the
cheerleaders went out there and danced
to like two different songs from top gun
it's like that's how it was a phenomenon
right and it's hard to find that these
days i think that's the magic of of 80s
of of top gun or any real major film in
the 80s go back and look at the lost
boys oh god lost boys um you know these
are films that that
really shaped who i am and we had so
many great films in the 80s i mean i i
saw all these films in theaters too you
go back to e.t
empire strikes back return of the jedi
aliens uh cocktail my god a cocktail for
as
as absolutely fluffy forgettable as it
is it is a film that i love it's one of
those guilty pleasures right and there's
so many of those in the 80s um but i
mean the lost boys was a film that i saw
and i said wow this is cool i just love
that's a film that is if you had 20 best
films i've ever seen lost boys is on the
list
even vision quest and i'm not a
wrestling fan but there was something
about that opening with the journey song
and that they're the best and and it got
you excited and and i feel like some of
that's lost these days well you know you
say that it's funny like you cocktail
the beginning cocktail like you said the
beginning that the starship song
that he gets on the bus and he's going
off to new york to be this uh big famous
business guy um is you remember those
things and like you said there's just
something about about the way 80s films
were made and i think that's what you
when you watch top gun maverick you see
that right when you see what kaczynski
did at the beginning of that film with
the intro with the top gun theme
bleeding into danger zone it's that's an
80s start right it's just here's your
here's your credit scene you're you're
beginning credit scenes which you don't
usually get in film these days and it
was such a smart move and i think that
sets you up for everything it delivers
but the 80s were i mean uh
again you could list a zillion movies
even going back to the you know garbage
slasher films these are all the things
that they got me into film
sure all the right moves they all got
you yeah yeah i mean
the diversity right the diversity
no the diversity of all the films that
that we had in the 80s uh just
it was just anything goes and i think
that um
you know
some people devalue 80s films and say
they're forgettable fluff their this and
that um but but i think of so many i
mean one of my favorite comedies of all
time is real genius with val kilmer i
mean the character
that val kilmer is in real genius
reminds me a lot i often wonder
did ryan reynolds watch
real genius because his persona and i
love ryan reynolds i think he's great
he's very good at that sarcastic snarky
guy
very quick-witted you go back and watch
val kilmer in real genius you're like
that is very much like what ryan
reynolds is these days i think val
kilmer in top secret same thing he's
just val kimmer kimmer's such an
underrated actor
i think we're all coming around to that
now with top gun maverick and seeing him
in the film and and certainly the
documentary from last year
uh but you know real genius is just uh
what a great comedy i could i've watched
that film probably 30 times